in stripes metallic hallways dripping
with the blood and viscera of your slain
enemies Easter eggs and radical cool
Duryea bound
we've been playing strafe pretty much
non-stop since launch so here's some of
the coolest [ __ ] we found so far
strophe is a game that prides itself on
its old-school roots so much so that the
games price is a reference to this it
costs 1996 sound familiar that's the
year quake came out finding it hard to
get out of the Eucharist levels just
break the glass to the right of your
starting weapons to spawn the wind
weapon reminiscent of The BFG from doom
once these babies charged up you will
lay waste to your foes the Icarus and
reality itself and be transported
directly to the end credits if you opted
not to loadout with one of the starting
weapons you'll find this handy monkey
wrench sticking out of the head of the
first two CS the scrapper you come
across its a one-hit kill that forces
you to get in close but while you're
using it random weapon pickups seem to
be more frequent
[Music]
the opening devolver digital logo is the
perfect 90s pre-rendered logo from the
heavy compression to the THX like sound
effects is everything a nostalgic gamer
could ask for
well almost if you head into the video
settings and enable make strafe look
worse you'll get some of the best
jaggies and blocky compression you've
seen in a video game since Metal Gear
Solid
elsewhere in straights menus you're able
to choose the gender of your unnamed
scrapper with this handy slider
[Music]
wizard about stripes levels our crates
and chests filled with enemies useful
perks and useless junk one such piece of
useless junk is a strafe n64 cartridge
look at it ah man glorious
there's a chance for you to get your
hands on the double-barrel shotgun from
super hot if you discover an
experimental weapons room we came across
it by blowing up a specific wall in
level one - once you pick it up time
will only move when you move up until it
runs out of ammo
it comes with 25 rounds and is actually
very helpful to lay waste to 25 unlucky
bastards if you shoot the dead scrapper
laying on the floor as soon as you
teleport to Icarus the body will jib and
it will drop a token pick it up and use
it on the randomly spawning Wolfenstein
arcade machine in level 1 - which is a
reference to both Wolfenstein 3d and
Vlambeer luftrausers if you get through
the mini game a box next to the machine
will drop prizes our weapon upgrades if
you make it to world for Athena labs
then you may recognize someone on the
monitors and computer screens across the
labs doom guy's face is plastered
everywhere hardly subtle but it's nice
to see an old friend
this last one's more of a tip than just
some cool [ __ ] if you consume four
pieces of food while at max health
you'll get a permanent boost in max
health by 10 so far we were able to get
up to 130 HP just there's also a piece
in the opening area it's just here you
should grab it before you start that's
all the cool [ __ ] we've found so far in
strafe but I bet you there's way more to
find let us know if you found anything
and make sure you subscribe so you don't
miss any of our coverage on the best
first-person shooters from this decade
and any decade before